okay
vehicle registration
another Insurance should be here
uh fax
you say you don't have the your driving
license no no uh I mean you you come to
my house all the time it's it's my uh
Danny Hernandez
do you have your license on you I know I
said no like three times
d-a-n-i-e-l-d-a-n-i-e-l yeah
h-e-r-n-a-n-d-e-z
good work
uh what else do you need insurance card
um right
hey do you know your license number no I
have no idea what's your social are you
social
I don't know much but you got afford a
driver's license yeah
so the address might be New York no I'm
saying it's a Florida deal it's not
gonna be a Florida State yeah Florida
State but yeah he's gonna be a foreign
all right
um
got a traffic going
to take me a joke for a traffic worm
yeah
I didn't know that
went for what though
I guess you received the ticket or
something that you didn't pay I never
received a ticket
go run
yo bro uh wait don't tell him you got
the card
all right yeah you got a traffic guard
so he's gonna be going to the
you want to leave your property with
your peoples are you going to take it
with you yeah all right y'all right you
haven't anything on your diet be
concerned about what happened
what's up for a traffic warrant you hear
this
you want to give it yet
y'all give that to Eileen just just take
her back home tell my brother where am I
going to do
you're right I have my bro I'm going to
punk Beach County Jail you're right yeah
Palm Beach County Jail Concord three two
two eight guys
foreign
[Applause]
bro
comes in your shoes
bring the slit back
bring it up to me
foreign
of the license plate they run it and end
up at my house
I think the DMV cleared this a lot
you got paperwork oh my God no I'm
saying you got to pay the paperwork for
that it's probably it's in my hot spot
hold on I showed you the license plate
right
so let's ask once I show you license
plate hold up I'll show you license
plate you can't all right listen you
know when the license they have it and
you have it right in the car
you know what I mean it's supposed to be
on the card no no no if if I get pulled
over and I and I and I and I'll show you
a license plate I have it it's just not
on the car every car no no it's no sir
I've been doing this job a while well
I'm telling you wait I haven't even left
my house you know right they're like I'm
still in my community I'm a gated
community right I'm in my house they
driving there my house is four houses
down I mean so like I said I showed you
registration on the wrong side of the
road and pass cars and you're because
you're in your neighborhood
all right
he said do you remember his phone number
Oscar Oscar Oscar come here
no
I gave Bernardo 6 000. the gun's only
two he got the cash on them yeah they
have to process you first all right
where I'm going Miami Gun Club Gun Club
it's down the block right behind Walmart
Southern and 95 yeah oh it's 7.95
you're waiting no no no no
but yeah
and depending on if they're busy or not
okay because we did then they got a lot
of people then it's gonna be maybe take
within those five hours all right no
problem thank you
yeah okay you didn't get your license
fixed too yeah no the attorney was
supposed to go you know what's so crazy
he just called I said they it should
have worn July 12th I said we've been in
and out the country for I I could say
from July
you got a warrant did I just tell you I
said that right and not only that they
issued the one no Customs because two
days ago yeah two days ago I just
literally told him that whole story no
but I told him what the reason why the
customers didn't see it because
yesterday
yeah he's like crazy right
well yeah I might have to take some
money back from him or something
because if your license suspended he
likes to spend it somebody ain't doing
their job
so what you said what you said um is the
I'm charged with no um suspended license
[Music]
um
I still don't get it
no no uh so what you said the charges
[Music]
um
I think I think I did but that was
handled because all my calls is is is is
not uh I put it under my brother's name
you know I mean I don't put nothing
under my name nothing
[Music]
yeah I don't have the registration only
yeah yeah you know what I mean but like
I said
yeah but they run the VIN numbers all my
calls belong to me
yeah
and they even have your registration
they gave the citation so
to see
don't you just give that to the Ticket
Clinic
the Ticket Clinic
that citation
no I said when all right so say you was
the one to get the ticket right
yeah
that's what I said they supposed to
handle that no
no
I don't know about this report
because
these it's a mandatory coordinate it
means that you have to show up oh so
that's probably what happened
[Music]
so we had what the no registration is
that
what the no registration
[Music]
no registration is Criminal
it's considered removing
consider of something that has a
mandatory but you said it's criminal you
just said criminal yeah I mean time with
you okay
[Music]
jaywalking is a citation too right
yeah it is so what that that's
considered like a criminal citation
[Music]
so I couldn't tell you but I don't think
that
I don't think it requires Authority I
think we just have to really find it
yeah you can't get the ones with a
mandatory
[Music]
I mean they should have told you bro I'm
surprised yeah like anxious was a course
and mail saying yo don't get in your car
you don't got your license suspended
yo you got to go to court
now you know what I mean like yeah
I know like they supposed to call me
like at the end of that I gave you all
my information if I if I was there I
would have been like yo what like
I ain't no clue that you know what I
mean
[Music]
I had what
you think
[Music]
I don't know that's what I'm saying I
don't know like
you know what's so crazy
I get pulled over all the time every
single time but the paperwork never been
a call but every cop knows my cars like
I got all my calls they know like I mean
like
yeah
yeah but I'm telling you like they know
my my insurance girl my license good
everything is always good that's why I
don't I don't care like about
now I know that I know that but I think
I I thought I I handled that so that's
why I mean
and if you said the warrant was issued
July 12th I flew in and out the country
like four times like
I I mean but
like I say this problem
you probably had
um
I fly out of um
I flew out of Miami I flew out of um for
I done did um four three private flights
One commercial
coming in regular Customs private fxc
Opa-locka fxc Miami
um yeah I think it was at um twice out
of Opa-locka no Twice out of fxc one out
of Opa Locka and one out of Miami so we
Miami-Dade
I don't know about Florida that's what
I'm saying I just know Opa-locka Airport
[Music]
um fxc which is in Fort Lauderdale
and then Miami is Miami right um
he probably showed up in the system but
it wasn't expeditable
like say if you had a war
that award shows and assistance and it
says
if it says in Miami pickup only that
means that we can't arrest you with
limey gonna come pick you up so if you
get caught in Miami with a warrant it is
it might be the only thing you'll go to
jail so it may it probably it probably
said uh Warren in Palm Beach County but
in County pick up only so that's
probably why when you went to customs
they didn't say anything because it
probably had any kind of pickup on it
meaning that he arrested down here pump
is kind of not gonna pick you up
it'll just wait till you get arrested
you get pulled over or something here
and then you know
because it's a misdemeanor it's not like
like a million times
that's probably what happened
so that's probably why they didn't tell
you hey you have a warranty system I
mean they shut up
I feel like they shut up
[Music]
say in April
okay
seriously
you receive a ticket in October last
year
I'm gonna win August almost a year later
I said so so from that ticket from
August of last year
that's over a year ago
oh you said October yeah that's like
that we almost out of year mark what 10
months later they just found my license
that's what I'm saying they always get
cleared up because I I provide the
Ticket Clinic with my registration
online I don't have that indicator
hmm
not that I really matter because at the
end of the day it don't matter but like
why y'all working inside a community
anyway because we've been getting
traffic
there's been a lot of people speeding
yeah
um I was literally about to go home